ah
[Música]
bueno dividen de que le voy a hablar del
bambú obvio y le voy a explicar sobre
todo porque soy una apasionada
se imaginarán que mi casa tengo mil y un
objetos de bambú además ahora cada vez
que hay algo bambú todo mundo me regala
y bueno es más ahora tengo las medias y
hasta un reloj de bambú
desde que crecí siempre escuché cómo es
que hay que hacer las cosas como ser
feliz cómo es triunfar cómo es tener
éxito el deber ser
y bueno poco a poco fui creciendo
siempre fui muy soñadora muy creativa y
cuando llegó el momento de elegir que
tenía que estudiar recordé que de chica
amaba a clavar y es clavar clavitos amar
y desarmar objetos así que dije bueno el
diseño industrial punto pero diseño
industrial y qué vas a hacer diseño de
objetos diseño de máquina vas a trabajar
en una fábrica para yo que nunca falta a
mi madre siempre me insistió a que
escuchara mi corazón hiciera lo que
tenía ganas de hacer pero nunca falta el
consejo que quiere ser un consejo y en
realidad bueno porque no estudia esa
arquitectura que te va a dar más plata o
estudia diseño gráfico que más conocido
yo que sé no yo fui me metí de ser
diseño industrial pero que es diseño
industrial
se supone que el diccionario es diseño
de productos a escala masiva en serie
qué tragedia porque yo no quiero traer
más objetos al mundo y seguir llenando
el mundo de plástico y de cosas porque
sí
de hecho la facultad me costaba era la
típica revoltosa porque me decían bueno
pero diseña imagina que tenés que
diseñar le a alguien que estudia y yo
que sé un reloj porque le todo diseño
reloj no era como bueno pero le
soluciona algo era como también generaba
mucha inquietud
pasaron los años y un día voy a dar una
beca para estudiar a china a china el
bambú durante dos meses
el bambú y la gripe en realidad visité
fábricas vi mucha gente trabajando
visité plantaciones hasta probar brotes
de bambú
y yo tengo que volver y hacer algo
predije para pero en uruguay hay caña de
bambú sí claro es lo que de seguro estar
imaginando en la caña tacuara imagínense
que durante mucho tiempo escuché no pero
eso nuevas bus
eso es caña tacuara si es con la que
hacíamos los arquitos de arco y flecha
de chicos o la caña de pescar es una
especie de bambú claro después de toda
la magia de china y todo lo que hacían y
todo lo hacían como ambú me encontré acá
con que no es una plaga crece muy rápido
es un problema no sabes lo que me pasó
en el fondo de mi casa yo decía pero al
contrario como me puede decir que es una
plaga es un problema más o menos que
decía en la palabra era sinónimo de
apocalipsis
bueno en realidad el bambú dicen que es
un regalo de los dioses porque porque
tiene un montón de ventajas a nivel
medioambiental es un recurso renovable
de rápido crecimiento
es fácil establecimiento fácil de
plantar y además tiene alta captura de
co2
además es fácil de transportar de
trabajar y de acopiar
y por sus características es bueno como
complemento a otros materiales como la
madera
además puedes enseñar lo que quieras
puedes construir de tu propia casa crear
energía hasta tu propio alimento
además
es clave para la regeneración del
planeta porque porque como planta la
genera los suelos y además como la caña
en sí es una herramienta en poder ahora
para regenerar el tejido social
así que dije bueno listo me pongo
acerado con el bambú como sea voy a
llevar esto a cabo voy a esparcir la la
magia del bambú por todos lados pero
claro no iba a ser la única dije no voy
a ser la única loca que esté hablando
cuando me fui involucrando a otras
personas porque además para crecer es
importante estar con otras personas
poco a poco empecé a recordar no sé por
qué siempre le pedí a mi madre que la
cuna la gana así que la guardara no sé
para qué para que cuando fuera grande y
tuviera hijos usarla hasta que me di
cuenta que en realidad de mimbre y bambú
y bueno después poco a poco fueron
floreciendo mi corazón un montón de
recuerdos que tenía con el one google a
lo largo de toda mi vida y que
evidentemente no estaba preparada para
conectar con él
con él aprendí un montón de cosas no
solamente en la vida emprendedora sino
en mi propia vida
de dedicación de que es tan importante
el proceso como el resultado
a ser flexible muchas veces me dijeron
que esto no es ahora no y bueno ante los
problemas y ante la dificultad es doblar
me pero nunca quebrarme
también a liberar mis propias
estructuras en lo aprendido
dejar el vacío para que fluya lo que
quiera emerger
en este camino nunca desaparecieron los
moldes ese que te dice bueno pero quiero
400 cañas todas iguales de punta a punta
todas de 4 centímetros para no me parece
usar caño de pvc no me tira pero para
eso en realidad cada caña es como que
cada persona tiene su propia
individualidad
y podrán ser de la misma familia de la
misma raza de la misma especie pero no
necesariamente cada uno es único y bueno
se darán cuenta que aprendí mucha
paciencia y resiliencia de no dejarme
meter en el molde
en este camino también aprendí mucho
mucha confianza y uno de los momentos
ajá que tuve fue darme cuenta que con lo
que había en la valijita de herramientas
de mi casa podía hacer lo que quisiera
con herramientas simples llaveros empecé
a desarrollarlos a mis amigos a los
muebles que necesitara y además darme
cuenta que podía enseñarle a alguien a
transformarlo con las herramientas que
él también tuviera así que bueno esto
llevó mucha práctica fiel o fácil a lo
más complejo y bueno hoy diseñó
soluciones de bambú y para eso les
quiero contar algunos ejemplos para
evidenciar más su versatilidad se
imaginarán que hay tantos usos como
personas como creatividad tengamos por
eso el mercado crece exponencialmente
día a día cada vez encuentra más usos
y bueno ahora les voy a contar algunos
ejemplos que me pasaron un día me
escribe un señor llamado bambú si van
gogh o sea me dicen que estoy loca pero
también me pasan cosas locas se llama
bambú
resulta que quería servicios para la
playa porque estaba cansado de la
contaminación de las playas con las
colillas de cigarrillos pero claro no
quería ser cenicero de plástico vamos
arriba entonces que hicimos ceniceros de
bambú para la playa cuáles son las
ventajas en este caso no teníamos que
hacer miles y miles porque el molde y no
sé que así es la cantidad que se
necesite además de baja complejidad
productiva
100 hecho con recursos locales y con
mano de obra local y además en el peor
de los casos si queda tirado en la playa
de biodegradable así que no pasa nada
otro ejemplo veían unas amigas bambú
ceras de chile y dijimos queremos hacer
un taller bueno cerca de mi casa buena
cerca de mi casa hay una carpintería y
mucho bambú
y justo en esa misma manzana vive un
señor que se acaba de comprar una
camioneta que es su herramienta de
trabajo dijimos bueno armamos todo que
hicimos un taller de estructuras
livianas hechas con bambú y que sirviera
para recubrir su auto y bueno eso estas
son otro tipo de actividades que sirven
para fortalecer vínculos para fortalecer
relaciones equipos como en actividades
de team building digamos y estuvo
buenísimo porque al final todos ganamos
otro ejemplo una emprendedora madre que
trabaja con niños pero además es madre
me dice estoy cansada de los juguetes de
plástico no quiero saber más nada
se rompe no sabes qué hacer con ellos
abundancia nn juegan 2 minutos y ya está
bueno qué tal qué podemos hacer con ella
rediseñamos la carpa tipi que todos
conocemos lo que tiene es que está
diseñado bajo conceptos de economía
circular es decir está diseñada de
manera que con caña finita que se
encuentra fácilmente en todos lados son
muchos lugares si se rompe la puedes
cambiar y además los insumos que
utilizamos son todos fáciles de
conseguir en plaza y además la propuesta
de esta carpa es que vincule porque
fomenta el vínculo entre adultos y niños
y bueno después de pensar mucho dije en
este camino emprendedor nunca fácil
dieta estoy haciendo de todo pero qué
más puedo hacer porque no me quedó
quieta y claro y no puedo esperar además
solamente a que la gente venga que la
gente bien que la gente venga a pedirme
cosas que ni siquiera saben que existe o
que se puede hacer para acomodado como
hago buena dieta me gusta dibujar me
gusta pintar estaba en un momento de
crisis dije qué hago porque si la gente
no viene pedir cosas que hago programas
no me gusta hacer objetos porque si dije
bueno está me gusta dibujar me gusta
pintar conozco muchos amigos quiero
seguir contando esto del bambú como lo
puedo contar
se me ocurrió
crear cuentos para niños que buscan
fomentar el vínculo entre niños adultos
y naturaleza es decir a través de los
niños en realidad aprender todos y así
nacieron las historias bambuser as que
bueno justamente además de todo cuenta
historias de amigos y gente trabajando
con bambú mientras que los visibilizó y
promuevo además que la gente se contagia
y sigue haciendo cosas
no sé si se habrán dado cuenta de que
tienen en común todas estas cosas
tienen un triple ganar para todos para
los individuos para cada persona para el
sistema social y para el ecosistema
natural para todos
así fue como conecté yo con la magia del
bambú por eso soy una apasionada y una
loca y bueno por suerte hoy no soy la
única hoy somos varios los que estamos
por lo pronto en uruguay de alguna
manera u otra con nuestras propias
habilidades haciendo cosas para un
legado sostenible y un futuro mejor
algunos trabajando directamente con
bambú otros inspirados en el por eso les
quería venir a contar que el bambú no es
una plaga es un regalo para todos
nosotros y las futuras generaciones
gracias
[Aplausos]
ah